hello everyone welcome today's ask the
expert panel this expert panel
discussion is presented by lab roots and
sponsored by get Co part of thermo
Fisher Scientific today's panel will
include the following experts Richard
Altman scientists protein technologies
at Amgen incorporated John zmuda
director of cell biology life sciences
group at Thermo Fisher Scientific Conrad
Mycoskie
scientist protein and soft Sciences at
EMD Serrano Research & Development
Institute and I'm Henry Chu I'm
associate director in cell biology life
sciences group at several scientific
Thermo Fisher Scientific I'm going to be
your moderator today so before we begin
I just like to remind everybody that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during this panel discussion I just
click on the green Q&A button located on
the lower left of the presentation
window and type your question into the
box that appears on a screen we'll try
to answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of actually during
the panel of this live panel discussion
please also notice that you'll be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window actually all you'll see is I'll
be switching back and forth from the
different panelists as they speak so
that you didn't just who's talking there
and to enlarge this window if you'd like
just click on the screen icon lower
located on the lower right if you have
trouble seeing or hearing your
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use a Q&A button
to let us know that you're having a
problem so just to begin this ask the
experts panel session what I'd like to
do is just take a few minutes each and
let each of our panelists rich John and
Conrad introduce themselves and tell a
little bit about what they do
particularly as related to Latina
compression work so
rich let's start off with you and then
go to John and then to Conrad okay sure
so hi everyone my name is rich Altman
and I'm here at Amgen in San Francisco
and the protein technologies group I've
been doing protein expression for
probably about 20 years at this point we
have a group here that is using both
transient and stable expression and a
variety of cell lines and in the
transient realm and variety of scales
she supports multi-site drug discovery
efforts
we're running scales anywhere from 24
you know a couple of mills in a 24 to 12
plate to weight bioreactors and are
focused on you know a lot of our focus
is on you know making our processes more
efficient how are we choosing expression
systems and how are we assembling our
expression toolbox to meet those needs
great thank you very much rich John you
thanks Henry for those of you that were
happen to be online earlier today to see
my talk my name is Jonathan zmuda
director of cell biology at our
frederick maryland site for thermo
fisher about 30 minutes due north of
Washington DC one of the prominent roles
that my team plays here in terms of
developing new products and technologies
is with the transient expression
platforms both insect as well as
mammalian 293 and Cho and one of the
things that we are continually looking
for is to understand the as yet unmet
needs of the protein expression
community I think one of the the common
themes that we all see is that no
one-size-fits-all and to use Rich's
terms you know what we look to do is
develop a toolbox of technologies so
that at some point in the hopefully not
so distant future whatever protein it is
that
you need to make and whatever quantity
that needs to be made in there would be
a tool at a high expressing system to
allow for that work to take place thank
you very much John Conrad I turn it over
to you
hi my name is Conrad McCluskey I'm a
scientist at Ian's Disaronno I started
almost exactly a year ago here and prior
to you in this Arana I work for 25 years
at Biogen and few smaller companies in
between I spent quite a bit of most of
my time expressing protein from various
cell lines insect cells mammalian cells
Choa Choa hybridoma right now at Serrano
in a group that is responsible for
delivering protein to to our projects at
Hydra food and small scale medium scale
and up to 10 or 20 liter scale that
that's our goal so anything between 15
mils and and and I'd say 10 20 litres
that's that's our roll over here and and
we were using predominantly XP 293 and
XP system as well as some Chile's stable
stable clones great wonderful thank you
very much Conrad so at this point then
we are going to open it up and this is
again asked experts panel so we
appreciate as many questions so we can
we already have a few for but for
anybody on the line you can you know go
ahead and start to enter in whatever
questions that you might have so let me
just start with a couple here that we've
already received in this the first one
here I'll ask is you know for for you
you three who are you know have done a
lot of work and I think you know and all
in both 2 9 3 inches cells you know what
type of differences you typically
observe in proteins if you express them
in to 9 3 cells versus Cho so let's
start with rich if you wouldn't mind
just a you know giving your
that's on that then we'll go there yeah
I think probably John and Conrad will
agree with this but I you know the major
differences that we we see is it's about
the glidecam profiling and so which you
know I think as I mentioned during my
talk that I think that system has opened
up a lot of a lot of efficiency for our
processes and being able to do that and
and I do think is I mentioned before
that again depending on the protocol
that you're running you're seeing a much
more production like glidecam profile
than you do in the in the 293 s but I
always throw in the caveat is that I
love the xB 293 system and that it is
really a workhorse and it provides a lot
of proteins in a lot of different
formats and successfully meets the needs
for a lot of requests that we have great
thank you observations from Conrad and
John if but I could add is I think
Matthew McKenna added also that and I
totally agree with that is that the 290
trees have much shorter cycles so if you
if you quit if if quick turnaround is
the thing that you need you can you can
exploit that 293 quick expression to get
the benefits of the higher title from XP
to you you have to wait 7 10 11
sometimes 14 days but that depends
what's the goal if the goal is to get as
much protein as possible than XP sure in
many cases is the preferred system if
the speed is what you need then 293
maybe maybe maybe more of a benefit to
you one more thing that we for example
would take advantage of is 293 media it
seems to be a little bit more iMac
columns friendly we finding a less
chelating or at least our
scientist industrial press inc find a
way to work around it while exposome
media seems to be causing a problem with
with using nickel columns okay great
actually you know you're you're you were
sort of answering a little bit of
another question that we have in here so
maybe I'll just go and throw this out
here now as well and you know you know
maybe John can start off but you know
certainly I'm it's great to see
oh and I forgetting to switch the
picture sorry about that but to just get
the interaction between you guys to see
what you say but here's a question that
is another question that came in so said
I'm interested in expressing GST or his
tag protein fragments for purification
and subsequent antibody production in
mice
so what system would you recommend to
produce up to 10 milligrams of protein
with native-like oscillation patterns
john will let you start off don't mind
yeah great thanks Henry
oh just a you know go back to that last
question very quickly I agree very much
with our both rich and Conrad on many of
those points the one interesting thing I
think with regard to the 293 and the cho
cells in general and they're in there in
terms of their biology is that the 2 9 3
cells really have a a quick burst of
protein expression and then they fizzle
out and very different than the cho
cells and you can really see why the cho
cells are so valuable as a bio
production cell line in the manner in
which that they ramp up their protein
expression and then are able to just
continue to pump out protein as long as
you keep them healthy in the culture so
very different than the 2 9 3 cells and
similarly along those lines what that
allows for is some flexibility in terms
of how you perform the protocols so for
example in terms of you know to get
protein quickly in many instances the
the rate of protein SP cho can be
simpler 2x be 293 but also there are
ways that modifications to XB Cho in
terms of transfecting at even higher
cell densities so very high densities
10 to 12 million cells per mil that will
allow you to make protein even faster
and can really rival or even how pace
the 293 system if you're looking for you
know about a four day turnaround time
from from the system and then lastly
just in terms of the differences in the
protein you know one of the things that
I think is still just just coming about
right now of proteins that Express well
in cho cells transiently and being able
to apply that to whether or not those
same constructs or signal sequences etc
will be successful in the stable cho
production so while that's still sort of
a a new and developing field you know
there's there some information that you
may certainly have some of that
information bleeding through to the
stable cell line expression as well in
terms of the GST or his tag protein
expression you know i think right now
you know as rich mentioned XP 293 has
been around for many years and has been
a workhorse for a lot of these proteins
and probably has a larger data set for
not antibody proteins currently than an
XP show but I think in general for both
of the systems and and either one
utilizing the correct resins for doing
the nickel purifications for example is
is critical all of the high density
media's and including the feeds have
componentry that can impact nickel
purification and so for example you know
some of the strip resistant resins such
as the excel resident etc we've heard
have been and we've tested been very
good at recovering hiss tag proteins
from the from the various supernatant
great thank you any rich or conrad any
experience on your end in terms of you
know tags and purification and as well
for you in does the work that you do
from my point of view is like I said our
dancing processing group the
purification group feels more
comfortable with dealing with media from
XP XP to 93 and they dictating to what
expression what expression system if
we're using if we're expressing fabs
with with his tag they they prefer if
we're expressing in to 93 system I guess
at that point the glycosylation is not a
nature forum and they just they just
want to have it Express and easier to
purified I will address and I will tell
them about what John said and then
challenge them if they've fully
exploited a complete your media if that
can be modified to purified on on the
same residence and and I totally agree
with John that this new ultra high
density system is very good substitute
for or 293 yeah and I think that I think
that speed issue and you know we keep
coming back to that but I think that
just continues to drive a major way that
we're thinking a you know getting those
XP chose and in and we to have
successfully done that a number of times
at that for DES and John's exactly right
what we see is at four days a lot of
times titers equivalent or superior that
what we see in the XP 293 s and also I
think one of the things and it's sort of
we're still sort of working on and I
don't know John maybe you have some more
comments about this but in some of these
format issues where we might see some
issues with product quality maybe that
shorter duration helps us not only in
just the process time but maybe in the
product quality time yeah absolutely and
I covered that a little bit in my talk
this morning that you know for depending
on the downstream use of your protein so
for example if you're making an antibody
as a reagent and what you need out of
that is you know you need as much as you
can get and it has good binding
qualities certainly you can push
in xbt all the way out to 14 days you
know 12 14 days make as much protein as
you can should be intact and stable if
you're trying to match like hand
patterns for example to a production
cell line that's something that you know
again you want to take a look at rich
was one of the the authors and some very
early work done with XV 293 and X beat
show showing that compared to a stable
cell line that expressing in X beat show
at 37 C compared to that particular
stable cell line generated glycan
patterns that were most similar to the
the stable cell line so understanding
you know again what the intended purpose
of material is is very important and
then tailoring your harvest time to meet
that and then you know outside of
antibodies non antibody proteins are
going to have you know different
profiles both in terms of their impact
on cell viability as well as their post
translational modifications
stability clipping etc all of those
things you know have to be taken into
account sort of on a per protein basis
and determine how far out your you're
able to go in terms of the trade off
between tighter and activity and
structure function and then lastly when
you talk about proteins you know either
toxic proteins or membrane proteins or
unstable proteins you know you may be
looking at harvesting at you know 24 48
96 hours and again that's all based on
the the nature of the protein so if you
think about sort of these three
different classes of proteins it gives
you a fairly good idea of where that
starting point is in terms of you know
where you should be looking to harvest
protein again taking into significant
account what the downstream
applicability of that protein will be
yeah I think that's a great point John
just in the sense of in terms of you
brought up about membrane proteins about
how that's probably for most of us
becoming a higher and higher percentage
of things that we're expressing and how
we have to sort of alter our harvest
time in some of our conditions to to
sort of coax the most out of that that
we can and rich it's a follow up on that
you know we we
are in the process of doing some fairly
significant collaborations around
membrane protein expression with a few
different outside experts and we you
know have recently press some proteins
in both xB 293 and xB Chow GPCRs in this
case using PC DNA vectors so 303 4 etc
and one of the strategies that has
seemed to so far been fairly successful
has been even using these these high
expressing CMV driven promoters we've
been able to significantly reduce in the
case of XP Chow the DNA going into the
system so down to perhaps point 2 or 0.4
micrograms of plasmid DNA per mil of
Culture Media to be transfected and
we've definitely seen that those lower
amounts of plasmid DNA are providing
higher expression of the the membrane
proteins and in these preliminary
studies we're seeing an X beat show that
the both the expression levels as well
as the functional activity of these
GPCRs are equivalent if not better to
what we're seeing in 293 and bacterially
expressed gpcrs again this being a small
data set right now with a significant
amount of additional data to come later
this year John on that subject when you
reduce them out of DNA for the membrane
expressed proteins right do you also
reduce the amount of X perfect timing
proportionally yeah so that's a great
question and this is another significant
difference between the 293 and and the
Cho system the 293 transfection reagent
you works best right around that one
microgram of plasma DNA and you know
with xB Cho you can use significantly
less plasmid DNA we showed some data
earlier today going down to 0.2 0.4
micrograms in certain instances you
could certainly even go lower than that
what I would suggest for XP Cho is that
if you're operating below about 0.6
micrograms of plasmid DNA so if you go
down 2.4 you reduce the amount of your
turn
section reagent proportionally as you
continue to scale down that will
actually allow you to utilize the
smallest amount of DNA to generate still
very good titers of proteins and so yes
it does become important to at some
point and again around 0.4 micrograms to
proportionately lower that the
transfection reagent as well so that you
have a proper stoichiometry of the
complex ation reaction but we continue
to do the entire complex ation reaction
in the normal volume that you would
typically use for for the protocol just
much less DNA and transfection reagent
enjoyed to you and John have you tried
the so you're reducing the DNA but do
you add sort of go back to the gene
dosing do you add or have you done empty
vector or something like that
to keep the amount of DNA constant so at
this point we we have not done that so I
think that is a you know a very you know
well-known strategy and that allows you
at that point to not have to manipulate
the amount of transfection reagent it
keeps the whole complex ation reaction
as is and there may be other you know
benefits there as well if you're looking
to slow down the expression of the
protein it's possible that those empty
vectors could you know soak up some of
the transcription factors slow things
down a little bit in the cells so I
think that's an excellent strategy we
recently had a case study for a
difficult to express protein where the
the group expressing it was using xB Cho
they they significantly reduced the DNA
level tested it at the two different
temperatures and and in fact we're able
to find a combination that worked very
well with the temperature shift but
actually not as well when it was at 37 C
so for some of these difficult to
express proteins you know we've we've
certainly seen instances where some will
express better at 37 c which in
typically if you look at the xB cello
protocol that would be thought to be the
the lower expressing temperature but
certainly some of these proteins Express
better at 30
seven and some at 32 so when you run
into these tricky proteins it's always
good to take a look at both of the
protocols and see which one is is
generating the best data great hey
thanks a lot guys do you create the
response to the questions as well as
additional work you could additional
discussion there you can see that when
you get a group of scientists together
the talk shop that a lot of interesting
points come out of that that's good I'm
gonna go ahead to another question and
just for anybody who's joined a little
later into our ask the expert panel just
a reminder that you know we're
completely open at any time if you click
on the the Q&A button and down at the
bottom you can write in a question and
you know we will be able to get to that
so here's another question that came in
I'd like to ask this this person is
asking should I we optimize expression
lenders that I use for transient
expressions in 2 9 3 cells to make them
more specific for expression in cho
cells and then you know how much more
eel eventually could I get if I were to
do that so Conrad I don't know if you
know I know you work with both sisters
if you'd like to at least start off and
whatever your observations are that PI
actually in our case it's all about
speed so we don't we don't optimize if
something does not express well if we
switch from one system to another we
just make more I think reoptimize avec
Therese would take too much time so we
we do not have any optimize vectors for
293 s or or X Patrol will use the same
the same DNA from one to another if he
doesn't express well in in 293 we switch
to the leg speed show using the same
plus in DNA okay thanks any and any
observations and your enrich or John
know so I I guess I would second what
Conrad saying that you know just I think
one of the
advantages in these systems is that
systems are pretty agnostic to the
vectors and so I think we've taken full
advantage of that over the years and I
think from you know trying to get to a
point where we minimize the number of
vectors that we have both for trending
and stable cell line generation it sort
of plays into that that we you know we
can sort of go in between systems
without reloading or doing any of that
or creating more constructs up front so
sorry the long-winded answer to that is
no we don't we just sort of switch
between systems using the same vector
and then I'll just add one small detail
they're a little bit off shoot but you
know typically we've found in you know
two nine three cells four for many years
now the thought has been to use a heavy
chain two light chain ratio of about one
to two for best expression whereas we
and many other groups seem to have found
that in the cho cells a one to one heavy
chain the light chain ratio and the
vector seems to be most optimal as the
cho cell seemed to do a very good job
expressing the light chain and lastly
you know when it comes to vector
optimization there's an awful lot of
anecdotal information out about
different vectors different systems
different proteins even and you know
that I think it's it's very tricky to
come up with a definitive conclusion
around you know which which vector or
promoter is is going to be best for a
given protein in a given system and
Conrad and Rich's points you know you
can chase vector design around for a
long time but if you if you need to get
protein made that's unlikely to be the
successful strategy to do so reasonable
amount of time yeah I think the whole
idea of transient system is quick
delivery and don't mess around with it
so everything is just comfortable ice
and you go with what you can double up
the volume if the tire is not big enough
and and move on yeah in John I
I totally second what you say about the
ratios you know that's that's much
easier to do if you're obviously if
you're
utilizing two vectors for that in terms
of the heavy chain light chain we find
the same thing about two to one might
change a heavy chain or I guess in the
past we've also done Irish solvents and
put the heavy chain behind the iris to
sort of modify that if we have a single
vector but yeah I'm fully totally in
agreement with you about that all right
thank you very much we have a question
here I know you know most of the work
that people do in transients are done in
shake classic so this person had a
question just about scaling and
particularly scaling up so the question
they have is when do you think it makes
most sense to you know when you're
scaling up your cultures I guess in this
context when do you think it makes more
sense to switch from large large shake
flasks to go into bioreactors when you
are trying to to picnic protein in
larger volumes John do you want to start
off with this one well you know actually
I'm going to defer that one you know
Conrad and I were just talking about
some of this work earlier Conrad do you
want to start off on that since I think
you know you you deal with that issue on
a weekly basis yeah so so I I'm kind of
like in tools in where we are worried of
the things on the very small scale like
literally 15 20 mils or the next step is
its a leader and up and then recently we
recently as I mean like November
December we started to work on a wave
back in collaboration with John and his
lab and and trying to figure out way
back and do you think a bioreactor we
didn't have much success with optimizing
bioreactor but we feel like we kind of
have way back figured out and and that
has been a big breakthrough for us now
we we can between the high titers and a
larger volume so we can do this becomes
very good very good system to express
actually grant quantities of protein for
for for larger studies so it depends
what the needs are but when you when a
combined system that
capable of expressing over grandpa
leader and and if you can optimize or
dial in your large-scale expression
that's a very powerful tool so it all
it's all needs driven but the the new
protocols they're coming up for wave
back and for a large shake flask or are
pretty much mimicking what the
expression is it isn't a spin tubes and
small shake flask so I'm no longer
afraid of the large volume so for you
when when do you add one what's the you
know the cutoff points and the volume at
which you typically are saying okay I'm
gonna move over to the bio reactors in
ways rather than anything so usually in
our case we do screen with the
high-throughput multiple constructs and
then we get a feel for how much they
express in a high-throughput scale and
if the tyrell dictates that for example
it expresses three or five hundred mils
per liter and I need five grams then I
know I'm gonna need I'm gonna need five
liters of it so at that point I can
either do five large check flask or or
way back pretty much at this point we
have overlapping scale that I can go
from spin tubes to lower to medium sized
shake flask to a large shake flask and
then overlap to to wave back so it's all
depend it's it's all driven by the
request right now okay thank you rich
any thoughts on your end or what how do
you typically make decisions in this way
if you do scale up yeah I think it's a
really it's a really good question that
I think you get in that range because of
the advances of some of these
consumables you know between the corning
five liter flat and the Thompson five
liter flat has sort of expanded what you
can conveniently do you know again
depending on your incubator space I
think you get up into that you know you
can easily handle the five liter scale
it's sort of a breaking point you can go
on to a way where you can keep it in the
flats and that's pretty easy to handle I
think probably most of the time now we
reach
and leaders and then we'd go into the
waves and you know we're using ways for
both you know stable scale ops and
transients and multiple systems I think
I agree with Conrad in the sense of if
you have one of these where you need
Graham or multi grand quantities the
wave is a great choice especially if you
have good tighter but the other thing
we're seeing is also one of these where
you have a low expresser and you need
you know half a gram and so the wave
becomes really you know an important
tool there too but you know also
tweaking the the conditions in the way
if we just had a recent case where we
had a pretty low express or non antibody
it's you know eight or ten makes per
liter and we needed five hundred MiG's
and so you know with some optimization
in the wave were up to in the range of
50 is seventy makes so that was that was
helpful and I think those lower end ones
you know those those lower expressed
errs but higher quantities relatively
speaking are also make up a number of
our requests these days so I think one
of the things that maybe Conrad can can
weigh in and John as well is that you
know how do you set that up it's nice to
be able just to seed the bag and expand
in the bag and transect in the bag and
now you're down to one vessel doing that
versus maybe scaling up in Flast and
then you know having to transfer all
that material on a volume basis into the
way but yeah I I think to get back to
the question though that once we get
above five liters we pretty much defer
defer to the wave although I was still
disappointed to your Conrad and the
bioreactor because we have a couple bio
reactors with two and a half and five
will your working binds downstairs that
I want to play with but I I think the
you know we have a good bridging
mechanism between those flats and the
lane at this point so you were
successfully but in an astute thing
bioreactors no I haven't tried them yet
and so it's one of the things where
it just hasn't breached the to-do list
up into a critical area and so but I'd
like to and I and I think that it's a
space I don't know what size your
bioreactors are these are relatively
small but I think it represents an
interesting space in terms of volume
what we could do probably realistically
I look at those bioreactors it's
something that probably helps if we have
a stable versus a transient just in
terms of better control that we have
over them to create a higher density and
more productive but I still would like
to explore them for transient use in
that sort of you know two-and-a-half ten
years days so where I see the bioreactor
being useful because there were tourism
I tried bioreactors that we had on a
loan over here and I tried two or three
times and and at the same time I was
working with waif and initially I could
only get small shake flask and then
medium and large shake was working and
later on we figure out how to do wave
work I could not have any more shots at
the bioreactor but I failed the first
two times and I still don't know what
because all the parameters were correct
for the transaction I think I learned
much more since then but I don't see
much of an advantage for the steerer
think bioreactor versus wave break
because they are relatively very
forgiving with what you can do in a wave
but now I'm more and more of a fan of
the ultra-high a transaction ultra high
cell density transaction and this may be
a place where if we can figure out how
to set up the bioreactor to for regular
transfection that maybe that sparging
capability of bioreactor may be
something that is needed for those ultra
high density transfection
other than that I can I can I'm very
happy with the way back and and and I
don't need to go in a steel tank unless
unless I'm we're talking you know over
50 liters scale
yeah I think that's a great point
because I think when you talk about
going into bioreactors the waves even
the new wave 25s are so so
straightforward to use and although you
have more control but I think you're
looking at an additional intellectual
investment it's really becoming facile
and he's in the more stirred-tank
bioreactors and so is it something not
only just from a process but in terms of
really grasping all of the engineering
principles in this in those bioreactors
and that's that's a whole different
level of investment and I think that
just depends on what you're using it for
but keeping it simple and keeping the
turnaround time you see it's much more
favors ways I then and I you know I
think on our end obviously you know
we're looking to support and the
protocol development of both wave and
start saying bioreactors and you know
many of the principles that we've
identified you know using the ready to
process wave units with the control
parameters and readouts we believe that
you know implementing some of them to
the stirred-tank bioreactors of which we
have work ongoing as we speak we hope
that some of those changes so with ex
bicho we found that you you have to in
order to scale up to the waves there's
some very slight protocol differences
versus the the shake flats and just in
terms of you know how the cells behave
in the wave bags the different levels of
control oxygenation etc and we we look
to put those principles into play in the
stir tank by reactors as well enriched
to your point about growing everything
up and transfecting them directly in
fact in the work that we are you know
doing currently with the the wave sort
of final optimization experiments we do
either seed at half a million or 1.2
million for either you know or three
days and just slightly over grow the
cells and then add some fresh media at
the time of transfection to bring them
down to six million such that it's a
very easy and straightforward
inoculation in the wave bags right the
one thing I like to add to it and I mean
the process of growing two of them and
I'm using the tell your bag and it's
it's hard to go low volume in a way that
I'm actually not comfortable with going
glow in a way that I would grow cells to
like six or eight I mean eight or nine
millions and then add fresh media to
bring it down to six so what we do
actually gram at four liter and a day of
trance fraction we drained some of the
cells at fresh media to to dilute them
down to six million and that's and we do
transfection in in a flask in a in a
hood and then we just weld the flask on
and we we added and what i was talking
with John's John scientists the question
came up can I make it quick enough to be
under five minutes and I actually timed
myself and I can add DNA and all day
perfect I mean and everything in a hood
with a cap on go to my wave weld dawn
and within two minutes I'm dripping in
less than five minutes everything is in
sorry go ahead rich I'm just going to
say are you actively pumping that into
the bag and do you are you concerned
about being harsh on the cells at that
point or is it just you're letting it go
in by gravity no no no cells are cells
are in a waves so those are grown in a
way bioreactor like kind of like the way
John described it we overgrown slightly
and then and drain what's needed
replaced with fresh media down to six
million and then I do my DNA X defect I
mean mix in the hood go to the buyer
active hook that up and then just ran it
by gravity gotcha
thanks yeah and using you know using the
the flask with transfer caps also works
well in some instances you know we've
had some issues with the tube fusers and
that can you know lead to significant
delays i think in general the team here
been utilizing the transfer cap flask to
just gravity drain and in that manner
able to very easily get the full
transfer within you know certainly
within five minute time period okay
thank you very much gentlemen here's a
question here just you know so what
features do you think that you'd like to
see in the next generation 293
expression system what do you think are
the things that that could be further
improved at this point oh let's see
let's start off John what are your
thoughts on this I know you you know
obviously we work together you're doing
a lot of development work on expression
systems what are your thoughts you know
for next-gen 293 system I think you know
clearly the the needs are always around
you know more protein while maintaining
quality and again you know the biology
of the 293 cells being very different
than the cho cells you know makes that a
difficult task to continue to improve
those titers but certainly that's
something that you know we we would all
want to drive towards and then also for
example you know there's a lot of small
nuances so XP to 93 having been out for
many years now you know we we provide we
generated a lot of great feedback from
from the industry and academic partners
around you know small thing so you know
for example the notion of his tag
purifications that had come up earlier
so there's there's probably still in an
awful lot of areas where tweaks along
those lines could be very useful to
making it a more you know an even
further rounded system and on top of
that you know certainly I think there's
interest in branching out these systems
into structural biology so potentially
some you know cell line engineering that
import
characteristics two proteins of interest
that are you know that I think will
build on what is already a very solid
expression foundation and move some of
these systems into even further utility
than than where they are today
great thank you rich what do you what do
you want John to work on is it just one
item I get to choose her can I have a
lot so I I agree with John on all of
that what he said about the 293 s but I
I think the other thing is in you know
John and I and YouTube Henry have talked
about this in terms of you know can you
do a higher density transfection in the
293 s and pushing it like you know have
some sort of equivalent like you're
seeing with the X be chose because
certainly as we point out even though
it's been around for a while it
certainly is a really valuable tool and
quite a workhorse but I think pushing
that and and you know to your point John
getting to you know more protein could
we do that and even have a shorter
duration you know that would be great I
still say the pressures on to make these
run durations as fast as possible great
any what's on your wish list Conrad well
I mean love of this very short coupling
time so if that 15 minutes can be reduce
down to five minutes that would be great
too so but I would probably require
changing the you know the the chemical
that you know the defect I mean port but
that's something that is slowing me down
a lot in the hood when I have to wait 15
minutes for this for this complex to be
formed so if that can be shortened to
the same way that X pitcher are working
that would be great improvement from
from our point of view because
especially the high throughput scale you
do one Iraq 2 X and then you can't
really do any more because you
have to wait for the first one I second
want to kind of get to the to the part
that you can add this I can you know you
cannot sell so if that can be speed-up
that'd be great
great wonderful thank you thank you very
much just work coming on to about 15
minutes left in this session so I'll
just again another reminder particularly
for anybody who might have joined a
little later that you know this is an
open session so any questions that you'd
like answered things that are high
interest to you please feel free to to
type in your questions into the Q&A box
and submit those I've got another
question here so this this one is are
there any particular tricks or
strategies to maximize expression of
chimeric proteins such as by specific
XFC fusions very similar or specialized
formats like that
oh who any volunteers to take this out
I'm not sure who has the most experience
with doing any of these types of work I
can you know just saw both information
that we've gathered you know over the
years you know certainly we have seen
that the cho cells oftentimes will do a
very good job of expressing some of
these more odd and unnatural proteins so
we we have specific examples in which by
specific type molecules have not been
able to been expressed in Prior you know
Cho or 293 systems and in fact in XP Cho
were able to see you know half a gram
three quarters of a gram per liter for
some of these proteins one of the things
that you know we we've heard often is
that certainly in the case of for
example FC fusion proteins some of the
experts in the field have suggested that
in terms of the ability to express them
in tact that the the secretion signals
can be critical for FC fusion proteins
and in fact the secretion signals and
the manner in which that the the
proteins are passing through the
secretory pathway of the cells can be
critical in generating intact and
unclipped FC fusion proteins such that a
construct that would initially
potentially be clipped somewhere in the
fusion partner with a with a optimized
secretion signal actually can be made to
Express intact so you know that's some
very interesting information along along
those lines so you know I think this one
is still you know a topic in development
and I'll you know certainly turn over to
comrade and rich who probably have
better access to some of these
constructs in day to day testing look so
so I you know I'll follow up with John
about that I do think that's interesting
I think some of the things you know some
of the things are pretty traditional I
think we come back to when I think of
some of these by specifics or whatever
it's sort of an interesting dialogue
between the protein engineers and the
expression people and each of us asking
each other what can you do for us in
terms of helping us out when we see
product quality issues with some of
these and and I do think it's sort of
you know both sides contributing to
solutions about this I do think in the
past I've seen when we've had some of in
a different format some of these by
specifics or fusions that are prone to
aggregation you know I've seen the gene
dosing being effective in terms of
getting a better quality product and
then of course you know the typical sort
of you know things about 10:00 shift or
run duration of course are things are
certainly things to try as well I don't
know you know and also we've we've
looked at
basically doing changing some of the
sequence parameters in terms of linkers
and linker lengths and this has been
over the course of years and years at
different places and that too can you
know have an effect I think you know
we're all in agreement about the use of
our time and I think it just depends on
the you know the the how strong you are
that particular constructor that
particular target is with how much
effort you go to doing all of these sort
of things in addition in terms of signal
sequences or gene dosing or any of these
so I think that's the other factor to
keep in mind I mean some things Conway I
probably can attest to as well you need
to have expressed no matter what and
others are like okay if it's not
expressed this this becomes sort of a
selection criteria in the whole process
so that's sort of some of our our
thoughts about that I agree with all of
that and another thing I can i can add
although this is kind of more like in in
many ways anecdotal is in my experience
a lot of this difficult to express
brought to express protein express
better at lower temperature it does
something the cells they they kind of
like seems to be taking the time
expressing the protein and in a way the
tire is higher because they express it
better they they assemble the protein
better so we found that often difficult
to assemble protein or Express but at 32
degrees which would indicate that X be
choicest and when you do the temp drop
is better system I don't have data
showing that if I use XP Cho at 37
degrees versus XP Cho at 32 degrees in
the XP 37 is going to be similar to XP
to 93 but that's the trend over here
that if we have a difficult to express
protein we were moving in over to XP Cho
and attempt to rob yeah in jhana
actually I'd like to pop and I might
even include the moderator in this
because he's been he's been kept out of
the fray but
you know what do you see in terms of you
know sort of cell line engineering with
some of these things I mean do you see
some engineering in terms of some of the
ER proteins in terms of you know
chaperones are folding or those sort of
things is something in the future that
will help this along yeah I think that
you know the the possibilities you know
really are endless in terms of cell line
engineering and I think one of the
things that you know we're working
towards again is to have you know solid
foundations of high expressing systems
you know multiple different host cells
and including insect work that that's
ongoing as well that you know provides
that initial foundation so you've got
you know one two three four
you know maybe five who knows you know
high expressing systems that that give
you that first shot at getting the
protein that you need and then you know
the engineering path I think there's you
know certain certain pathways that can
be relatively easily modulated through
cell line engineering to provide for
example protein that is better for
crystallography or you know potentially
ways to improve the expression of toxic
proteins through the modulation of the
timing of expression so there are
certain things that you know you could
imagine would have sort of a wholesale
approach or a wholesale benefit to
expressing certain types of proteins for
certain uses and then the other issues
around you know over expression of
various chaperones or anti-apoptotic
molecules etc those become a bit tricky
in that you know are they molecule
specific you know do you need to express
a certain set of chaperones for you know
each one of these difficult to express
proteins and and does it then become
even feasible to have engineered cells
that more or less are you know capable
of handling every hard to express
protein so you know there may be there
there may be strategies there in terms
of cell line engineering as well as
potentially other as yet unknown host
systems that may you know be less
impacted by some
viii very atypical molecules that are
going into clinical trials today great
thank you thank you very much looks like
we probably have time for probably one
maybe two more questions in there so let
me give you this one here so yeah you do
you ever see any problems getting
expressed proteins to be secreted from
2/9 years or cho cells particularly in a
situation where you know the protein is
fused to for example a GST tag for
subsequent purification work hey I'm not
sure if which if any of you have some
experience with that either GST tags or
having difficulties with expressly or
getting secreted secretion of your
proteins I mean I can I can certainly
start with an interesting anecdote that
came from one of the roundtable
discussions recently at the pegs Boston
conference from from Adam Esposito over
at Lee dose and this this question came
up and Dom's response was was very
interesting in that you know anytime
that you're trying to take a protein
that isn't secreted and doesn't
naturally move through the secretory
machinery of the cells you you can be
asking for trouble because that protein
obviously is going to be acted upon by
you know many different enzymes etc that
it normally is not expected to to
associate with so there may be
significant post translational
modification changes in trying to drive
a on secreted protein to become a
secreted protein so I think that one is
you know something that you you you
weigh those potential risks and and what
may be changing with the protein when
you're trying to push it out of the
cells
which obviously is a a more streamlined
approach to producing the proteins but I
think one has to be cautious also on
what you may be changing by having the
protein expressed through the secretory
pathway where it is not typically
exposed to a natural expression Thank
You comments Conrad I don't have an
experience as expressing GST tag protein
in in 293 or Cho souls I've done a lot
of expressing with GST tag protein but
they were only in insect cells and the
only thing that I always remember that
GST helped me to tag and purified but
very often when the tag was removed
subsequently the protein crashed out of
solution because like John said that
protein does not like to be the way it's
constructed to begin with and GST
stabilize it but then once the tag was
removed the protein crash out of
solution anyway but that's that's a
totally different issue but in terms of
expressing this protein in 293 or Osos I
don't have an experience with GST tags
plenty of haystacks no problem here but
no no Jeannie Dex reliant thanks yeah
any last comments from you now rich on
this no I'm with Conrad about that one I
think it's an interesting question just
in general what the efficiency of
secretion is because I think a lot of
times we you know we get the result but
it would be interesting more than just
sort of sporadically but when you run
into a problem and you think something
is you know what we're tighter than what
you'd expect and you go and look and see
is and it's not going to sell or
whatever but what the you know what
what's sort of our acceptable levels or
what should we expect in terms of the
secretion efficiency so but I haven't
done tags need in one of these systems
GST times in my system all right thank
you very much I think in the last four
minutes this last question I'll ask for
you that was submitted in here was
so for a year in your experience when
you're using transient work and doing
culture volumes of one liter or more
what's been the best way that you've had
to to clarify your that culture
supernatant to then move it on for
purification work rich maybe you can
start off there since I already have
your photo up there okay so this is this
is something that is inserted well fear
to everybody's heart because I think
it's it's it just takes a lot of time
but we're looking at a couple things
besides center Breguet ssin now in terms
of using these dual filter units from GE
and in terms of being able to just plug
and play just hook these up to the bag
through the sterile connections you know
start pumping it out and be able to walk
away for the hour to that's required for
it to go through the clarification and
then sterilization filters in there and
then end up in a sterile bag and that
that we've had some reasonable success
with I still think it's a work in
progress but it certainly frees up some
time for us to do other things I think
we are also investigating right now use
the use of magnetic beads that are
coated with protein a or hiss to drop
into the bag say into a wave bag the
night before harvest and then the next
day using a magnetic rod basically to
pull those beads out and to move them
from basically from one container to
another where you are then washing and
then eluding off in a in a concentrated
way is that it will take about an hour
and a half that we now have gone through
a clarification a first step
purification and a concentration step is
really exciting to us and even better in
terms of saving time but that's
especially helpful I think when you get
above you know a few liters that are
about five liters for
that that gets us away from the
gentrification stones great thank you
very much
any last very quick comments on this
clarification question there Conrad so I
agree or fridge that I saw the
presentation at San Diego and those
magnetic beads were that was great and
the way they were they were you know put
in and the system they built around it
that looked great
they were very promising it kind of you
know ignore all the cells and you pull
everything at once the only thing I can
add is I've been experimenting with
Thompson's this new filter that is
escrow on filter and that seems to be
working well for me as well it has it
has some limitations on one hand it's
the size four or so definitely probably
but it's a great great system that you
can just screw on on on a flask and pump
it out of it I guess the benefits of it
or the trick to it is that by vacuuming
the cells on right and then pumping on
you know creating pressure vacuum it
increases the throughput other than that
we on a smaller scale we just centrifuge
heart and and filter it using various
there is devices all right great thank
you very much exactly in 30 seconds okay
just chime in very quickly you know we
we are also looking at alternatives that
I know other groups are as well in terms
of the utilization of diatomaceous earth
on top of the filters which can allow
for pouring cell containing supernatant
directly over filters does a nice job of
pre-processing the samples as well as
other bio production types of filtration
mechanisms including flocculation of the
of the culture supernatant to remove a
lot of the gunk before passing it
through the filters so certainly and
clearly there's a lot of work going on
here as this is a inherent bottleneck
wonderful thank you thank you very much
I really do appreciate the all the
questions that have been submitted and
like to think very much our expert panel
here John rich Conrad thank you very
much for your time and for lending your
your expertise and your knowledge for
this session thank you very much for
that I'd like to also thank the lab
roots and give Coe part of their
official scientific for making today's
webcast possible additional questions
will be answered and published on
Thermo Fisher Scientific website and
you'll receive an email notification
when answers are available before we go
I just want to let everybody know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through April of 2018
so you were received from an email from
lab roots letting you know that this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may be interested that
utilizes and today again that's all
thank you very much for joining us for
this we hope to see you again at a later
date thank you very much goodbye